c'est alin
champfor alors si vous vous voulez
écouter mes chansons vous cliquez là et
si vous voulez vous abonner à Ina
chanson vous cliquez
là mur auquel je suis
accroché ça mais de toi de savoir que tu
es
parti avec le
jolier déchaîne
moi fallait m'achever pas me faire
prisonnier je veux plus avoir la boule
au cœur et au pied allez viens au pied
au
pied
je vois tes yeux tes valises fin prêt
pour le départ tuas brancher les prises
pris tous les
mouchoirs reviens donc me déchaîner où
je casse toutes tes cailloux c'est pas
bien ce que tu as fait mamène comme ça
au clou qui s
mal conduit et qui troule en code la
nuit en code la nuit si c'est pas le
monsieur qui t'a enfui alors déchîn
moi je peux plus voir ce mur auquel je
suis
accroché dire que c'est pour lui que tu
as décidé tu Valé la
clé déchne
moi j'ai une interview je te quitte en
mattend des visitesie une
cagite le
blanc t cheveux qui se débinent
j'enillis pas la fin on a que Demi mine
un
tigreorin reviens donc me déchaîner où
je te met en colère après nos années
d'ors me recoller au fer qui sa
mal conduit et qui troule en col la nuit
code la nuit si c'est pas le monsieurs
qui tong les son de
souvenir je peux plus voir ce mur auquel
je suis
accroché
oh dire que c'est pour lui que tu as
décidéavaler la
clé
déchanemoi fallait m'ach pas me faire
prisonnier ça m de toi de savoir tu es
parti avec le
jolierch
moi fallait m' pas me faire
prisonnier je veux plus l'avir la boule
au cœur et au pied allez F au pied au
piedch
moi
pour découvrir ou redécouvrir mes
chansons vous pouvez vous abonner à la
chaîne Ina
chanson